so your baking show nailed it was
nominated for an Emmy right yes yes
Paul's drag race which I get it it's my
favorite show I truly love it it's
hilarious it's so good yeah did you get
to meet anybody cool have you ever been
to the Emmys before no I've never been
to the Emmy I mean now I have a teenager
but before you know singers don't
generally know I guess so what was my
first Emmys it was very glamorous I
loved it there was just famous people
very close to you which is like a real
delight yeah mérida lie well yes but
they're all well they're walking around
with publicist so they can't have they
don't have time to be mean you know yeah
but uh I saw Viola Davis and I loved
Viola Davis I also saw her on a plane
recently and I was like I need to talk
to her but then I was like she's living
her life don't do it so I didn't do it
but then at the Emmys I was like this is
a work event I could talk to whoever I
watch I just pitched it to people I was
like I am bothering you box I need you
to know I love you and she truly was
like half eating a hamburger I was like
oh my gosh she's very sweet
that's awesome yeah I know she's amazing
I'm a big fan of hers have you fanned
out over anybody before I'm Stevie
Wonder oh well yeah I recently well a
couple years ago I got the chance to
work with him he worked on one of my
songs went into his studio where he
actually can can actually function in
the entire studio walk around nobody's
help he knows exactly where everything
is and every time he come up comes
across there he'd be like nice to see
it's nice to see you I'm like Stevie's
back stop with the bacon thing
that's awesome you know everything is
that's awesome just be like a
comfortable place for company yeah yeah
I mean he's in there every day you got
to work with Stevie Wonder that's
amazing there is an interesting story
about your driver's license which I kind
of connect to but I want to hear yours
it's amazing okay so I bought this big
wig from a drag queen wig faker as we
did you know I was truly feeling myself
I was like the bigger the wig the closer
to God exactly truly that's how I walked
through the Glendale DMV and everyone
was like what is it
and then in my Netflix special currently
streaming on Netflix I had a joke about
why why is your weight on your driver's
license who's gonna question it like my
driver's license used to say 150 pounds
yeah and I wrote it down in the lady
truly just like squinted at me and I was
like I dare you I dare you to say she
didn't say anything so I was like the
next time I get it renewed I'll put 90
pounds so I you legit have 90 pound
driver's license says 90 pounds
[Laughter]
like has anyone seen like it's like when
you show people today as anyone then
nobody has clocked it but I'm waiting
for someone to be like where your leg
like I I can't wait I'm gonna put like
two pounds the next time I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this